with a worldwide haul of 2.7 billion
dollars avatar is literally the most
successful film ever made and it's
actually pretty good too
well if the fans are to be believed
anyway Cameron's gorgeous and vibrant
world was something that people just
want to hang around in and when they
couldn't they got pretty bummed out when
I woke up this morning after watching
avatar for the first time yesterday the
world seemed gray it was like my whole
life everything I've done and worked for
lost its meaning slow down though that
doesn't mean avatar was perfect between
all of those dazzling special effects
were a few dumb things in Avatar that
everyone just ignored basic biology
let's not even get into the science of
growing an alien hybrid clone and taking
control of it with your emotion but what
happens to human bodies while they're in
those pods
we're told Jake spends a 16-hour stints
in that little box but how did he like
use the bathroom are they wearing
hi-tech diapers or are they just
following Austin Powers Todd rules we
don't see anyone hooked up to anything
in the box so are they just holding it
or is there a drain at the bottom or
something and to a larger extent why not
add a feeding tube hamsters do it we can
do it convenient straws involved science
that we've already perfected for total
idiots so why can't we do this in the
future Jake loses weight and it's
constantly reminded to eat when he comes
out of the pot they can control alien
hybrids with their mind machines but
they can't build in stuff for basic
bodily functions we expect more from you
future do your homework
Jake is recruited to relocate to pandora
but he seems pretty much clueless about
everything in pandora he skipped over
the extensive training required to be
part of the Avatar program and just read
the manual instead how much lab training
have you had I just check this program
everyone knows you don't skip the
tutorial especially if it's your real
alien body on the line yes pandora is a
beautiful new world but Jake doesn't
know his avatar ass from his avatar
elbow he messes with plants that could
be poisonous and he doesn't know the
first thing about the indigenous animals
that he
tasked with protecting his team from
which doesn't stop him from shoving his
ponytail into one which is gross the
film obviously needs a character to
serve as a way into the story but the
dude could have dug a little deeper than
Pandora's Wikipedia page
why use avatars at all the entire
concept of creating these alien avatars
doesn't seem like a wise way to build
real trust with an alien civilization
the Navi are smart enough to understand
that humans are different than they are
so why do they think that making these
fake versions of the aliens will help
them connect haven't they seen Star Trek
disguising yourself as an alien rarely
turns out well and then you have to get
down with a nerdy alien and everything's
a mess now we're hoping if you make love
to me what also if you're really trying
to blend in you have to go native so why
the heck do they still wear human
clothes on their avatar bodies if you're
going to all the trouble to build this
insanely expensive alien body
you probably shouldn't dress like a
tourist lost in pandora we are asked to
believe that in the distant future
science can create alien avatars that
can be controlled through thought but it
can't track them what the natives doing
the Funky Chicken here to document blade
well it's going really these people have
to learn that we don't stop they can
barely even ID their guides visually it
almost killed Jake with a bulldozer even
today is the grunting Neanderthals that
we are we can track just about
everything from our dogs to our cars so
what's up high-tech future when Jake is
separated from the team they have to
scour the woods to try and find him
tracking isn't that hard even without a
global network of satellites and
especially not a century into the future
we found Waldo
we found Carmen Sandiego and we can find
Jake and his fancy alien body late to
the game the Navi have a fighting chance
during the big faceoff at the end of the
film because Jake travels around pandora
and rallies the different tribes to help
fend off the sky people it's too bad
none of the Navi thought of this sooner
the entire Navi culture is built around
a respect for nature but this is the
first time they've considered the idea
of teaming up to try to
push these sky people out once and for
all all it took was a non-native hero to
come in and fix all the dumb navi's
problems or maybe getting the Navi to do
their own version of the Care Bear stare
was really just a weak plot contrivance
the giant knife it made for a cool
bizarre moment when Colonel miles
Korach's robot pulled out his own giant
knife during a fight but the whole thing
is wildly impractical if you want to add
a bladed weapon to your giant robot
build it right to the arm robots are
made with all kinds of awesome
contraptions and hidden doodads instead
the robot designers created a holster
for the knife and then relied on a robo
handle hold it which then drops it even
bb-8 had a lighter tucked away in his
gut and you know what as far as movie
knives go it wasn't even all that
impressive noise
that's a thought thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]